- my future president when you're sworn
into office next January the majority of
Americans will wish you were someone
else
you won't be popular you will have the
power to decide whether our country
continues down a road of globalization
and endless war my hope is that you'll
choose a different path my name is Ramon
Mejia I'm from Dallas Texas in 2001 I
graduated from high school had a newborn
daughter and like many young people of
color no way to support my young family
I ended up in the Marines and 2003 I was
part of the first Marine combat service
support unit deployed to up the next 7
months of my life would be spent in a
country that we brutally invaded and
occupied all under the guise of national
security I was discharged from the
military like thousands of my fellow
veterans I was discharged due to health
issues resulting from my service you
never served in the military you don't
have your children you haven't seen war
from the perspective of combatant or as
a civilian whose country has been
invaded yeah you will have the authority
to send young men and women to fight
commit atrocities for the sake of
corporate entities profiting from the US
military 'sm our national security has
thus far been self-serving we've
militarized police departments we've
normalized mass surveillance civil
liberties are an afterthought
stop the fear-mongering stop the
polarizing debates stop saying what your
base wants to hear speak sincerely and
truthfully about the issues we need to
confront as a nation don't speak about
the military threats to our national
security
ignoring the ways our foreign policy has
created these crises don't ignore the
mother's raising children and refugee
camps because of our policy decisions do
you have the ability to either continue
exploiting national security fears for
continued occupation of lands abroad or
stop I hope you choose to stop Ramon
Mejia set up a Mexican immigrant
Muslim manpower veteran